bonjour pour cette dernière chronique
avant les grandes vacances je suis venu
avec un livre qui parle d'expérience de
vacances et le premier est bien concerne
un petit renard qui part en vacances
un livre de sophie ledesma publié aux
éditions la martinière jeunesse pour
immortaliser ses vacances il a un petit
appareil photo qu'il va prêter aux
jeunes lecteurs à partir de 2 ans et
grâce à lui eh bien il est possible de
chercher des détails dans l'image de les
faire apparaître en général ce sont de
petits animaux qui vont accompagner les
enfants pendant tout le voyage alors
c'est un livre très jolie acidulé qui
plaira beaucoup aux enfants et qui
permettra aux parents de les préparer à
leurs vacances de leur apprendre
quelques mots de vocabulaire et surtout
est bien de s'amuser pendant les grandes
vacances
j'ai un autre livre qui parle de
vacances alors celle ci ce sont des
vacances un petit peu plus tumultueuses
car l'héroïne doit faire face à un grain
de sable
la soeur des vacances cette serre des
vacances c'est une soeur que son papa
fabriqué avec une autre dame que sa
maman alors ce livre d'emile chazan et
de galles sous part publié chez gaultier
langeron explique bien le problème
auquel est confronté une petite fille
dans une famille recomposée
elle aimerait se réjouir de partir en
vacances chez son papa mais il y à cette
petite soeur qui la suit partout
c'est un livre sensible où tous les
personnages sont nuancés et je vous
conseille vraiment à l'aube des vacances
si vous êtes confronté à cette
problématique c'est un très très joli
livre
les dessins sont très beaux et
l'histoire est très touchante
puis tout à l'heure je parle de la plage
mais il ya aussi les vacances à la
campagne comme celle de pilot qui part
chez mémé pour les vacances
le héros de julien mariole s'inquiète un
petit peu alors ils préparent tout un
tas
de jouer à emporter et il espère ne pas
rester trop longtemps
finalement au fil des pages on découvre
qu'il va trouver beaucoup de source
d'amusement dans cette campagne se
rapprocher des animaux et surtout qui
n'entretient une excellente relation
avec cette grand mère on manie très
touchant très amusante
alors vous retrouverez certainement vos
grands parents dans cette bande dessinée
elle plaira à toute la famille à partir
de 8 ans je la conseille c'est à mettre
dans vos bagages pour cet été et enfin
si vous avez envie d'aventuré d'évasion
il faut absolument emporté ce roman
graphique de xavier coste qui est partie
du roman d'henry bosco l'enfant et la
rivière l'histoire est simple un enfant
à l'interdiction de s'approcher de la
rivière
donc il y va et elle lui révèle ses
secrets
alors dans ce livre magnifiquement
illustré vous verrez une rivière comme
vous ne l'avez jamais vu tournoyante
hypnotisante envoûtante elle change à
chaque moment du jour ou de la nuit
c'est un roman d'aventurés fantastiques
à la fois ça plaira aux collégiens aux
lycéens à leurs parents à n'en pas
douter je vous le conseille c'est un
très beau livre publié chez sarbacane
alors j'espère que cette petite élection
vous donnera envie de partir en vacances
avec de la lecture et je vous souhaite
de très belles vacances